the family of 58-year-old stephanie
turner is devastated after she was
killed trying to cross a street on an
electric mobility scooter it happened
last night near las vegas boulevard and
silverado ranch kate houston spoke to
turner's daughter and she joins us live
tonight with the latest kate
yes we learned that turner lived in a
senior community just down the street
from this intersection behind me where
she was hit now both the residents of
that senior community and family members
of turner are pushing for more safety
measures here wondering how many more
people should die before something is
done
yeah she was the wife of the party she
was loving
she was a christian woman
stephanie turner's family is heartbroken
over the loss of their mother i moved
her out here and the last two years was
the closest we've ever been
turner's daughter christine says her
mother was always positive which helped
lift her spirits as she battled ms and
other health challenges she had gone
through so many things like if something
were to take her out was an accident
it's insane because
her mental strength was so strong turner
is not the first person to be killed at
the intersection of las vegas boulevard
and agate residents at the senior living
facility down the street say it's been a
problem for everyone nearby it's the
most dangerous crossing i've ever been
on
because
there's such a length between the lights
that their people can't cross and the
lights are not really timed that well
anna hardaway avoids going out at night
for fear of not being seen and getting
hit do i have to take my life in my
hands every time i cross the street and
it feels that way now residents and
turner's family are calling for changes
saying there's too many memorials on las
vegas streets and it's far too many
they're building the city
too fast and they're not thinking about
the people who make las vegas great
back out live people living nearby say a
four-way light stop signs or a flashing
crosswalk would all help them feel safer
on this street and clark county says
that this is a tragic accident and they
will be studying this intersection to
see if any changes are warranted
reporting live from las vegas boulevard
and silverado ranch kate houston live
local now